of course yes now he always has time for
his fans children all over the world
grow up watching Disney movies on repeat
but it's no secret that Disney hides
mature themes and discriminatory
messages inside of their films although
times have changed and Disney has
adapted dozens of countries have banned
their movies for both justifiable and
outrageous reasons find out why the
live-action remake of Mulan is causing a
stir in China and watch until the very
end to find out why the beloved movie
Aladdin was boycotted for being racist
where these nations being too sensitive
or was Disney truly in the wrong
give us your verdict in the comment once
you're done watching Disney's
live-action remake of Beauty and the
Beast was a total hit but a few
countries did have issues with the
character Lefou the film was momentarily
banned in Russia when it was said to
clash with one of the country's laws in
Russia there is a law that prohibits the
spreading of gay propaganda among minors
so many officials believe that Beauty
and the Beast would be too inclusive the
movie was set to be released in mid
March of 2017 however it was momentarily
bans when the Culture Minister received
complaints officials held a screening
before allowing the public to watch it
stating that it would be permanently
banned if it was deemed illegal after
watching it officials voted to unban the
film but they did add an adults-only
rating to it meanwhile in Malaysia the
mere mention of the foes character
caused religious upheaval the country
refused to air the live-action remake
until Disney cut certain scenes from the
film but according to Straits Times
Disney released a statement saying that
the film had not been cut and would not
be cut for Malaysia
shortly after their announcement
Malaysia agreed to air the uncut version
but only in a handful of theaters powers
it no girl has snatched you up yet I've
been told them clearly but I really
don't get it
the live-action remake of Mulan has been
a highly anticipated movie ever since
Disney announced its making however some
major factors have come into play and
they have been detrimental to the film
success in China Millan hasn't been
banned in China but a large sum of its
citizens have chosen to boycott the
movie news of the live-action remake and
it's Asian cast was refreshing at first
seeing as there was an outcry for Asian
representation in Hollywood that's how
it feels to be a minority and that's why
representation is so powerful however a
comments made about Hong Kong police by
Yu Fei Liu EE angered millions of
Chinese citizens resulting in a huge
boycott despite China's initial
excitement things went south when lui
re shared a Post's friend the People's
Daily newspaper that read I support the
Hong Kong police you can all attack me
now
Chinese protesters were outraged by her
repost calling lui anti Hong Kong
although millions are choosing to
boycott the Disney film China has had to
close thousands of their movie theaters
amidst the coronavirus threat which will
impact Disney's initial release in China
your job is to bring in 2018 the
oscar-nominated movie Christopher Robin
premiered in theaters all around the
world except for in China where the
Winnie the Pooh character had become a
symbol of the resistance now you're
probably wondering how a famous little
teddy bear became the subject of
controversy in the world's most
populated country and well the short
answer is at the Chinese leader Xi
Jinping had been censoring Winnie the
Pooh images months before the film was
even announced
you caught me here authorities banned
the use of winnie-the-pooh on social
media to stop people from linking Xi
Jinping to the lovable bear according to
Hollywood Reporter the Chinese leader
was being ridiculed online for
resembling poo and he was more than a
little sensitive about it on top of that
when he had become the face of
anti-communism when the subject of the
Chinese ban on Disney's Christopher
Robin became global news didn't King
also censored comedian John Oliver for
joking about the ordeal on his show he's
annoyed about it means people will never
stop bringing it up Avengers endgame was
produced by Marvel Studios and
distributed by Walt Disney Studios
motion pictures in 2019 it was one of
the biggest movies of the year and
received some great reviews however the
film's release date was delayed in
Russia and the movie received a
temporary ban until certain matters were
worked out the reason for this being
that one of the Russo brothers plays a
gay character in the film he attends a
support group with Steve Rogers and
briefly talks about going on a date with
a man what did you talk about
Massimo crap you know how things changed
Disney soon revealed that the movie
would not be screened in Russia with
English subtitles
this way Disney would not have to alter
their film so the version was banned in
Russia a Russian dub was created to
allow the movie to circulate however
this revised version would be altered to
fit Russia's strict role on gay
propaganda instead of using the word
date the Russia voiceover artists use
the word time which made the statement
less LGBTQ friendly however Disney is
unwilling to change their english
subtitles for the russian law which is
why the English subtitles are still
banned today what a date the other day
it's first time in five years
Disney's Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise has been wildly successful all
around the world but some of its
installments were deemed too sinister
for the public which was the case for
the 2006 sequel Dead Man's Chest
according to independent an official
from China's film Bureau reviewed the
movie and came to the conclusion that
Dead Man's Chest was much too graphic
since its plot revolved around
cannibalism the movie was deemed as
horrible and unsuitable for audiences
since cannibalism was a pivotal part of
the plot
about to begin Jack's life will end
these scenes could not be cut without
compromising the storyline of the film
and so the movie was banned in China
independent also reported that Chinese
authorities were unhappy with the way
the spirits of the film were represented
generally movies that featured too much
gore ghosts or explicit content are
banned in China still some movies make
the cut so it's impossible to predict
how Chinese censors will reacts to any
given film what would any of you be
willing to do hmm Disney's The Little
Mermaid has not officially been banned
in any particular country however a few
stores throughout North America ban to
sell the movie due to its explicit
videotape cover the initial version of
the VHS cover had phallic shapes
embedded into the background which
consumers quickly spotted and complained
about while many parents did not spot
these controversial images those who did
were absolutely insulted by the
subliminal images the artists of the
cover stated that the phallic shapes had
not been intentional in many interviews
nothing happened
still customers urged stores to pull the
Disney classic from their shelves and
many of them obliged nevertheless Disney
refused to alter the cover admits the
scandal but to prevent further outrage
Disney did alter the cover on the copies
sold outside of North America the VHS
cover was eventually recalled and now
decades later the original covers are
being sold for hundreds of dollars on
eBay
in 2018
China banned a handful of American
movies for various reasons and two of
those were highly anticipated Disney
films a wrinkle in time was the first to
be banned by Chinese officials followed
by Christopher Robin so why was a
wrinkle in time denied release in China
well China has an annual foreign film
quota which limits the amount of non
Chinese movies the country can welcome
into their movie theaters however this
wasn't the sole reason why a wrinkle in
time wasn't given the green light well
dad always told me to stand up for what
turns out the novel the movie is based
on has also encountered its fair share
of problems the wrinkle in time book has
been widely controversial ever since it
was published in 1962 it was one of the
most commonly banned books
in the world religious groups were not
fond of the novel scientific and
religious undertones however the fact
that the movie is a bit too complicated
for children also play the hand in the
verdict these themes clashed with
Chinese morals resulting in the movie
being banned trust Wallis I'm not sure
about neck give her a chance okay
Disney's Moana hit the big screen in
2016 and quickly became a fan favorite
everything from its animation to his
storyline and soundtrack was amazing and
the one and only Dwayne Johnson voiced
the mighty Maui making it that much
better
but Moana wasn't free of controversy
despite its heartwarming messages
although the film was not banned in
Italy Disney was forced to change Mona's
name as well as the name of the movie
Italy requested a name change which was
a pretty big ask
however Disney wanted Italy to showcase
their new film so they agreed you did
everything for them so they love you
they changed the movie's title from
Moana to Oceania and the reason behind
the request is quite surprising turns
out an actor named Moana posi who was
famous for shooting adult films had
passed away in 1994 and the name Juana
still reminded the population of the
late celebrity Italian officials didn't
want parents to get the movie confused
with the late celebrity which is why
they firmly requested the name change
for James Cameron the making of Avatar
has been a lifelong passion project
Disney acquired the rights to the
franchise and is taking a huge risk in
continuing his vision this is especially
true since China bans the first avatar
movie in 2010 in early 2010 the Chinese
government ordered its movie theaters to
stop screening the biggest movie of the
year tell me you're joking
despite the film racking in over 73
million dollars in just two weeks
the movie was such a hit that Chinese
officials began to view it as a threat
according to Hong Kong's daily Apple the
Chinese government feared that the movie
would inspire citizens to revolt like
the Navi population did in the film as a
result avatar was banned in over 1,600
Chinese movie theaters
and no one can stop him moving well we
will send them a message in 1992 Disney
released the animated film Aladdin but
despite its global success many
religious groups were triggered by the
movie's content which led them to
boycott the film first of all the film
wasn't voiced by Arabic actors which
offended the Arabic population as well
as many American Arabs so by the time
Disney chose to make a live-action
remake of the film in 2019 the company
swore that it would be more inclusive
while getting rid of any racist
annotations no one steals in the movies
opening song Arabian Nights
there was a racist lyric that referred
to the Arab culture as barbaric this
stopped many teachers in the Middle East
from allowing the movie to be watched by
children this bias lyric was finally
altered in the live-action remake but
even then the Arabic community still
felt like Disney wrongfully portrayed
their religion and culture it's time you
start doing what you should have done
all along stay silent and that's a wrap
on why these ten Disney movies were
banned in other countries before you go
tell us if you think these countries
were overreacting or whether or not
Disney was truly in the wrong sound off
in the comments ala forbid you should
have any daughters thanks for watching
don't forget to Like and subscribe for
more we'll see you next time on the
things
you